hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and there is a
new trailer for guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 and yeah I know new rock stars
have switched back to using a blue
screen which means you at home can do
all kinds of weird embarrassing stuff
with this footage hey what are you doing
stop anyway this trailer gives us our
first look at Kurt Russell's character
ego the Living Planet father to
star-lord Peter Coyle
Plus more shots of baby Groot that dare
you to make animated gifts out of them
and more vivid colors that makes the
rest of the MCU look like an ashtray or
the color of my shirt so in this video
I'm going to explain everything about
ego and all the other new stuff in this
trailer skipping over the footage that
I've already covered in our previous
trailer breakdown so let's get started I
hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute
is that a rifle you don't know what a
rifle looks like it's just swords were
your thing and gun for mine but I guess
we both doing guns now I just didn't
know that absence
so like in past trailers this one opens
with more shots of this battle with the
a ballistic that's the interdimensional
monster that the Guardians have been
tasked to defeat by Aisha and the
sovereign early on in the movie so the
applet speeds on the sovereigns energy
supply which I'm now guests saying might
be what these things are we also finally
hear Gamora speak in one of these
trailers you know what a rifle looks
like she has this fun back-and-forth
with quill giving us the taste of this
movie since the humor but then the
subtle detail that I really like here is
this device that quill is using to
detect the Ovilus this is a Mattel
electronics football game released in
1977 and it looks like quill has
modified it from a crappy handheld game
into a radar like energy detector and
I'm guessing that this thing was in
Peters backpack when he left earth as a
kid along with his Walkman and mixtape
alright let's move on
I see it within you yeah
jealous creo okay so in this section we
hear that same great song choice from
last trailer late would max the tame
with baby Groot apparently playing it
from quills Walkman Brut is wearing this
awesome little jumpsuit here but and all
the other shots we've seen of him in
this battle he's not wearing anything so
either this shot is from like a
different scene or it's possible that
James gun shot this scene specifically
for the trailer which is something that
he's been known to do and as Aisha lists
all the negative qualities that she sees
in the Guardians
I like how we hear jealousy over this
shot of Gamora glaring at nebula so
these two half-sisters hate each other
with nebula feeling jealous that their
father Santos loved Gamora more than her
we also see new shots of rockets
confrontation with the Ravagers with
yondu's Yakka arrow hovering in front of
rocket space but notice how yondu spin
isn't there yet I feel like this could
be early in the movie shortly after the
Ravagers are sent by Asia to capture the
Guardians bud before taser face
overthrow Zeon do and yondu joins up
with the guardians and escapes with them
anyway I'll come back to the shot but
let's move on to doc you cleanse the
universe of this weakness
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
dude I'm using my wrong eyes okay so
here we see that this swarm of ships
chasing the Milano and the other
trailers belongs to the sovereign you
can see their golden faces with cockpits
there so here's our forming this grid
and I wonder if it's going to be like
that huge net formed by the Nova Corps
ships at the end of the first movie we
also get some more context on ayesha in
the conceited mindset of the sovereign
they want to cleanse the universe of all
these weak qualities and yeah a superior
race wanting to cleanse everyone else
you're not looking very good there Aisha
and yeah I love this bit with rocket
dissing the sovereign and Winky and at
quill with the wrong eye food rocket
you're surrounded by sovereign it
doesn't matter which eye you wink with
they're gonna know you're being
sarcastic I think they're going to
cleanse you first all right moving on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in this next turn we see that it is
impossible to have a shot of baby Groot
looking uninteresting here Groot is
eating candy like M&Ms or jellybeans or
something and out of what looks like the
flowerpot that he initially grew out of
also this might be the space candy that
was advertised on quills shirt like I
know in my very first teaser breakdown
last fall I pointed out how people
online translated that alien language on
his shirt two gears shift but according
to Chris Pratt during that visit it's
just like a candy logo like maybe one of
the guardians pass mission hooked them
up with a bunch of free candy and merch
also it looks like this gravity snare
thing that we've seen rocket use on the
Ravagers actually has a few moving parts
with the darts flying out of the trees
at them and I'm guessing rocket laid a
few booby traps behind a fort the
Ravagers and then maybe they aren't
enough to overwhelm them and he ends up
in their custody I don't know we'll see
let's move on so it came in the galaxy
again we're really going to be able to
jack up our bright super 2-time galaxy
David
[Music]
okay still a few things here now that we
know these are sovereign ships
it means the sovereign will be part of
the showdown in this odd looking cavern
place which I speculated in the past
might be the core of ego the Living
Planet in planetary forms also we saw
the shot of Gamora with their sword in
the first teaser but now baby Groot has
been CGI'd into the shot there's also
this slightly wider version of the shot
of Drax showing more hunched over the
background possibly injured you also
might have noticed that the last trailer
had Drax saying screw you spaceship
instead of yeah so I'm guessing that
line is from a different theme and I
liked Rockets line here about saving the
galaxy a second time mostly because as
many of you have pointed out despite all
the footage we've seen we still don't
know who or what the guardians are
saving the galaxy from like we know
Aisha is one of the villains and they
fight the a ballistic and taser face
leading the Ravagers or the problem for
them and sure maybe ego will be
threatening the galaxy in some way but
James Gunn still really haven't given us
firm answers on any of the big questions
about this story so it'll be nice to
walk into this movie without having
pieced together every little scene which
is pretty much all I do these days
there's also this shot of quill and
Gamora dancing which we'll talk about in
a bit but for now look at the more in
this next shot we saw her using this
massive gun last trailer but now we see
what she's shooting at her sister nebula
who we saw flying this ship and the
other shots trying to gun her down so
this confirms that once again the
tension between these sisters is going
to get really nasty let's move on
[Applause]
so in this section there's an
interesting shot of Drax using the pulse
rifle that we saw him grab in the
earlier shot and notice how we wait for
the charge before he fires also his body
is covered in this bluish texture like
I'm wondering that that's a bubble so he
can breathe and space or something that
enables him to fly and it may be from a
different scene but the editing in here
makes it look like Drax is firing at
this massive ship larger than anything
else we've seen and I'm wondering if
this [ __ ] belongs to the real Big Bad in
this movie whom we haven't seen yet
maybe whatever character Sylvester
Stallone explains could be connected to
this and then after my favorite part of
this trailer which baby Groot waving at
Gamora mid-battle and hurricane hi we
get this interesting shot of mantis now
look at the background here it looks
like that same cavernous place that
we've seen before but those coral
covered tentacle pieces are moving as if
this whole location is forming around
her to me this could be more evidence
that this location is actually the
inside of ego to living planet and that
we might be seeing the transformation
process of egos human form turning into
a planet core alright moving on some
time
good thing you're searching for your
whole life it's right here by your side
all along you're right
oh you do with your family
familiar
so here we see a beautiful master shot
of this colorful planet surface now I'm
not sure where this is my first instinct
was that this is the surface of the
color pool underground plates that we
saw
making in this place possibly the
surface of ego meanwhile apparently
James Gunn said on Twitter that it's the
planet of the sovereign but he might
have just been gripped in this person's
awful spelling now wherever this is it
means to have a strange emotional effect
on the guardians like remember quill and
Gamora danced in this earlier shot and
even though there's been chemistry
between the two I just don't see that
happening naturally also Drax and Gamora
gaze at these floating bubbles and they
have the same childlike wonder of the
clintons with balloons remember that was
the thing that we laughed about so it
seems like this place might have some
intoxicating effect on the Guardians
transporting them into a new dreamlike
State we also see the surface of this
other planet exploding which also feels
like it could be the planet form of ego
we'll see I feel like everything we're
seeing this trailer is ego just zoomed
in I also enjoyed this job with nebula
calling out the Guardians love-hate
relationship with each other and then
Drax somebody in his interval with his
[Music]
enough family now it's ironic how he
excludes nebula from that family when
she's really the only one in the group
who has actual family ties with another
in the group unless mantis is it being
half-sister to Peter quill but really I
don't see any resemblance there all
right let's move on to this final
section with the reveal we've all been
waiting for after all these years I've
found you and who the hell are you I'm
your dad bitter okay so let's talk about
the man Kurt Russell ego the Living
Planet taking a human form who conceived
Peter quill with Peter's mother Meredith
quill so I've talked a lot about ego in
these trailer breakdowns quick refresher
in the comics he's been both friend and
fro and fro Rand info mostly he's just
self-interested in super moody the name
ego so we really don't know what role
he'll play in this story and I like how
for the Kurt Russell version they gave
him this majestic beard similar to the
facial hair shape that the planetary
version has in the comic and then notice
this ship that he comes out of with
mantas we've seen this ship location
show up and a bunch of other trailer
it's noticeably in the trailer when we
first met Mantid and I think it's
interesting that the white and yellow
colors and general shape of this ship
make it look like a giant egg like I
feel like that had to be intentional
maybe implying that ego and its human
form hasn't hatched yet and when he does
he'll transform into his true planetary
self and finally I'm thinking this
father-son reunion will happen close to
the midpoint of the movie because check
out nebula here she's still handcuffed
and her left hand is a claw like a crude
replacement from when she got her hands
severed in the first movie like I'm
guessing she uses that to like pick
oranges or something meanwhile in the
awesome group shot that we've seen
before she has a new hand so I'm
guessing that takes place later in the
film maybe even the final shot and that
this new hand was created for her by
perhaps ego okay that's everything I
noticed and let me know what you thought
about this new trailer what do you think
about Kurt Russell and egos Living
Planet and be sure to check out my other
three breakdowns of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 trailers like I know I
skipped over some of the stuff in this
trailer it's because I already covered
it pretty comprehensively and one of the
other videos and if you like this video
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and if you really like us you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our current patrons
especially Kelly hopper you can hit me
up on twitter at EA vas if any thoughts
or theories that you have about
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 or follow
new rock stars on twitter at new
rockstars for info about when our videos
are coming out ok thanks for watching
seriously again get it out of here take
five
[Music]